right
so you got a shorter side and a longer
one yeah you're toing off at the handle
here so this knot that I'm doing is
um deemed to be 80 H sorry 70% the
strength of the
wire which isn't too
bad it doesn't
slip and you can use it on short
strains and it comes up pretty
neat that's how fast it is when you can
do it well well it's quicker than
putting in a Crump or anything you know
yeah and
um my wire strainers are Rusty because
nobody seems to be able to build good
wire is these days that don't
slip so yeah show it again uh
slower slower yeah
so what
you
yeah around the first and then the loop
and around the
second
each of these wires is uh tension to
around 150
kgs and I'm pretty confident that this
particular fence will stay that tight
for the next 30
years because
um we've used 2.7 M strainers all driven
all the foots are driven
yep and um
so here we're just at a corner it's
going from this is about halfway down
the line yeah
halfway about um from there
somewhere industry standard yep is for
these these lines to actually be tied
off on the strainer so that there's no
um knots on the line except for joining
knots of wire where your coil Runs Out M
but um that's good and and I do tie off
a lot of fences in that
manner but uh this works really well on
a long strain you need to get even
tension from both ends and like to say
the knot is um pretty strong and it
doesn't slip see this no sharp edges on
it or nothing like that yep and um it'll
be fine it'll stay here for
years
then you got to put some buttons on
everywhere three three for every panel
yeah so this is a 9 wire fence and it's
a pretty standard fence for New Zealand
conditions I really like it because
uh by the time you put three BTS on this
fence there Ain nothing going to put its
head through it and hassle it and it's
tight tight like a guitar you know and
um they ain't going to get through this
ever and then that means that I can
finish this job and look laying should
be as good as you like you know
yeah those where the five first and the
last four in here yep yep I set the
strainers so that
um all the
knots fall in a row as good as you can
get but the reason for that is when
we come to batting this fence there's
going to be a bat in here and another
one here so all of those knots are going
to fall um down in the
middle and it's not hard to change the
um strainer to do that
oh yeah but you got to think in advance
where you put your nuts yeah because of
the buttons of course yeah yeah so I'm
just trimming off here what I need to
uh work with the rest is just Surplus so
this is about how much wire we've pulled
out of the strain the strainer fence
yeah so if you have a look along here
we've built around 200 M here between
the two
uh both ends nothing like this is the
the last of about 1.2 km that we've
built in this particular job M so it's a
relatively short
strain and
um the rest of them are around between 3
and 400 m which some people would
consider quite long for one strain but
I'm a real fan of um having a long
strain because
it takes advantage of the elasticity of
this wire it's just like a piece of
elastic really I mean we're dealing with
high tensile wire yep 2 and 1/2
mil and uh a little short piece like
this feels very hard but over a great
distance it becomes very
elastic and um you've got to take
advantage of that so that you do have
something move in your fence line for
example if a foot comes up um that wasse
not going to lose much
tension but of course you try to set it
up so you can't do
that we've had a trials on this job
there's been a lot of um angle post to
put in which is like this one here and
um three of them we had to
blast
and those three took a day's work each
by the time we blew a hole into solid
POA and then blew out a big crater
and then got down 1.2 M deep stick the
post in foot and then you got to find
all the Rocks get them back in the hole
and by that time your M will pack the GE
up and call it a day yeah all all those
corners and uh and strainers they're uh
deeper in the ground than uh over the
ground longer under uh this one here is
the same length in the ground as it is
out yeah but all the ones at the end of
the line are um uh how far are they in
to uh
right
1300 shouldn't move with
this you hope not but some of this [ __ ]
ground around here is letting us down a
bit we've got to make sure that we put
foots on them
and we're lucky that we're doing this
job in in the winter time well you know
wet season anyway so that it makes us
think really hard about putting foots on
that aren't going to move yeah because
you can get fooled In The Summertime by
coming around and thinking oh it's nice
and dry here we can
um just put a little foot on and away we
go come winter time and this ground gets
really wet and you've got a tight fence
it'll move which
is unfortunate but yeah we just saw
before we had to put a huge foot and
replace that's right
yeah and
um let's we get trapped trap for young
players I've had many years of doing
this and I've I can I
can proudly say I suppose proudly say
that everything I've learned I've
learned the hard
way because when something fails and
believe me I've had a few things fail
you go and have a look at that and ask
the question why and you do what you
know you learn from it next time you
think right ain't going to let that
happen so you
know I'm still trying to build the
perfect
fence have you done it
yet I'm working on the
right I'm too fussy for that I I I spend
too much time picking holes in my own
work
and
uh wire strainers can be a dog to deal
with and I've found for years that if
you just put them on a little safety pin
like that M you've got them
all and then you can drop them on the
ground or do whatever and carry them
over your
shoulder and you can you've got them see
you can drop them on the ground here and
you pick them all up by grabbing that
and not losing
them good cuz I wanted this one up the
front easy to deal
with yeah whole bunch whole
bunch that can be pretty heavy to carry
up to have 20 of these but um yeah oh 10
and 10 together load I used to have
20 but
um useless buggers that I've had working
for me over the years of lost
them is it expensive a strainer like
this I think they're over1 130 bucks or
something each now
yeah and what annoys me is you know
there's two main companies who make wi
in this country and they still haven't
got them perfect
well they're working on
it so these are all my scrapes that I
just
made yeah take back all the [ __ ]
yeah still got either end to clean up
but hey yeah that's all good part of a
job
yeah oh yeah good so just buttoning for
this one and it's done well you know
this fence is stock proof
now but
um bons will just trip it off honly
know